[Music]  hi checking in its what's 45th birthday  soiree years this place has its own  magic I think you're gonna look smell  nice this is such a great spread on a  wiener watch fingers sweetie it it's  nice to get away and unplug this place  is just so relaxing time to get our buns  in gear for our thoughtful hunt so is  that a plan my caddy today we have birds  of prey watching it's nice to get a  break from the group right honestly I  just need a drink we're doing whatever  the f we want  [Music]  Catherine where's your face so tight did  you put on a night cream bundiada  bundiada bundiada bundiada I was her  diagnosis and she's mentally quite sound  great thing about life you can feel fine  but I also know that you're a ticking  time bomb  why do you have to be so controlling  about everything I just want to say I'm  now ready to forgive all of your  bundiada boom  [Music]  you